normally behind the camera on wednesday
tv producer bao choi was the subject of
media attention as she faced her first
day
on trial sorry i cannot speak much
before the legal proceedings
greeting the veteran journalist at court
were a group of supporters who say
this trial is an attack on hong kong's
media freedom
we feel that we have to stand up for her
as well as standing up for
freedom of press in hong kong
bao choy has been charged for her role
in a tv documentary
that exposed what he'd said was police
misconduct
during the anti-government protests
central to the investigation of
allegations
police colluded with a group of gang
members who violently attacked
pro-democracy supporters in a train
station
in 2019 troy used a government database
to identify the owners of vehicles
near the location that night police say
that information was obtained illegally
media groups say choi was just doing her
job this does raise questions about
government transparency when it comes to
data and potential
uh legal terrorism when the authorities
uh go after reporters you know in quite
weird wonderful and
innovative ways i don't think anyone
would have expected that this freelancer
would have been arrested over something
like this this trial has intensified
concerns over media censorship
in hong kong this territory was once a
bastion of press freedom in asia
it's now fallen to 80th in the world
press freedom index
and the introduction of beijing's
national security law in july last year
has increased the risks for journalists
reporting
on potentially sensitive subjects media
tycoon jimmy ly
has been arrested in recent months and
remains in jail
the city's public broadcaster rthk
also suspended its oldest satirical show
after accusations it insulted the hong
kong police
some international media organisations
including the new york times
have moved the asia digital hub and a
third of their staff
to south korea there has been an ongoing
restriction
or restricting of the base for free
reporting in hong kong each of these
incidents is different in its own way
but together
they paint a pretty clear picture that
you know independent reporting is under
some threat in hong kong this is the
first time a journalist has been put on
trial
for coverage of the anti-government
protests
bow choi has pleaded not guilty but her
supporters fear
her arrest may not be the last sarah
clark
al-jazeera hong kong